الصراع على النفوذ ينطلق من قلب اوروبا
ويتجه هذه المره الى قلب المحيط الهادئ
الذي تحول لبؤره توتر عالمي وجبهه قتال
محتمله بين روسيا ودول الغرب الدفاع
الروسيه تدق ناقوس الخطر وتعلن رفع حاله
التاهب القصوى لاسطولها في المحيط الذي
لطالما كان ساحه الصراع قابله للاشتعال
بين الاطراف التي تسعى لتعزيز قواتها
العسكريه في المنطقه خطوه روسيه حملت معها
رسائل التحذيريه شديده اللهجه من قبل
موسكو للغرب مفادها ان الاسطول البحري
الروسي في المحيط الهادئ لديه الخبره
القتاليه لصد اي عدوان محتمل فاعلان
الجهوزيه القتاليه وفق مراقبين جاء ايضا
كرد على التحركات العسكريه اليابانيه تجاه
جزر الكوريل وهي جبهه اخرى تسعى روسيا
لتامينها بعد اوكرانيا البحريه الروسيه
تتشكل من خمسه اساطيل مهمه تتوزع حول
مراكز الصراع المائي في العالم غير ان
القدرات الخياليه للاسطول الروسيه
الموجوده في المحيط الهادئ تشكل حدا فاصلا
بضمه العديد من المعدات العسكريه التي
تشمل المدمرات البحريه والفرقاطات وكاسحات
الالغام الاسطول مقره فلاديفوستوك ويضم ما
يقارب 50 سفينه متعدده المهام تمتاز
بالسرعه والمناوره وسفنا سطحيه للعمليات
في المحيطات والمناطق القريبه من البحر
كما صخرت روسيا 23 غواصه استراتيجيه
ونوويه متعدده الاغراض تتحرك على هذا
المسطح المائي ويعد اسطول المحيط الهادئ
جزءا لا يتجزا من البحريه والقوات المسلحه
الروسيه في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات